the Joe Rogan experience but I don't
know I always had this joke of like my
teammates that I was going to get famous
by being like the Nick the nip slipper
like I would use like certain like muy
Thai clinch techniques to just like pop
the girls move out so I'd always get to
fight the popular girls because like
they knew oh she's fighting Paige
Vanzant we're gonna see some patience
and titties you know and now it just
like you know raised my style I haven't
done it though but I try it on the guys
in the Jones lift the shade up anybody
ever done that on purpose in a fight no
no I think the one person that backfired
with was I don't remember who she was
fighting but Leslie Smith's boob puffed
out once the room yeah in one of her
Invicta fights and she did not give a
[ __ ] she's crazy
yes God you can see into her head yeah
stop the [ __ ] the photos like this
girl's gangster
she's insane I love it I love it she's K
and she's so like nice yeah like such a
hippie you know outside of that it was
like a really funny what is she doing
now she's still trying to start some MMA
union yeah she's still she's still going
hard with the unions she's in Bellator
now um but I think like the big Union
that she was working on was only four
years see fighters I believe hmm so I
think she's still doing that I think
she's still fighting for the UFC
fighters even though she's not an EEOC
does that what it's I haven't looked
into that like I haven't looked at like
what are they what do they want what are
they trying to accomplish what's not
correct that they want to fix I think
just any any grievances that the
fighters have in general so like health
care salary just things that everyone
kind of agrees on is like not good
enough yet in the UFC I think those are
the things that they're working towards
how does health care where are you guys
covered in training or you only covered
for
it's um as far as I know if you book a
fight and you get injured
I think they cover it but I think it's
also a gray area where like they could
not cover it and they're not legally
obligated to fix you but I think in the
past they have I'm not sure I can't
think of any any examples where they
haven't like you know taking care of the
medical expenses of someone who got hurt
but I know like a lot of times fighters
don't claim it in time like after fights
or it's like a little nagging injury
that becomes a big deal further down the
line and it happened in the fight but
they waited too long yeah yeah either
that or just you know just wear and tear
from training in general like you can't
I can't go in for like a loose tooth or
like or like a shoulder that I taught in
practice if I wasn't getting ready for a
fight what seems so crazy because you're
obviously fighting in the UFC of a
long-term contract yeah you've been
fighting in the UFC for years if you're
training you're training to fight in the
UFC yeah exactly
and I think I think a lot of instances
they still take care of the fighter but
I know like if you're like on the lower
end if you haven't really made a name
for yourself yet sometimes you know even
if you just don't ask like you don't get
taken care of it's not like it's not in
your contract once you sign like oh I'm
gonna fight this many fights but there's
nothing in there that says if I get
injured after signing this contract I'm
covered medically so um so yeah I think
that was that was the main reason I was
like oh this is a good idea just because
like I know so many fighters who book
fights just to get their injuries taken
care of hmm you know or they though
fight injured and claim an old injury
and like and that's their way of fixing
whatever they broke during training so
that sucks
it's horrible it's such a [ __ ] crazy
way to make a living period yeah you
know it's like you're you're deciding
you're gonna throw your bones at someone
and
to break their arms try to rip their
legs apart and this and then you're
gonna practice that all the time and
then you're gonna hope you don't get
hurt in practice to the point where you
can't actually just go do it inside the
Octagon yeah yeah exactly and most of my
injuries happen outside a camp because
I'm either training stupid training with
someone I who who I shouldn't be
training was like someone too big or too
inexperienced or or I'm just like
[ __ ] around like when I'm fighting
someone who's my size is a lot less
likely that I get injured right but when
I'm throwing my bones like I said at
somebody who's way bigger than it's easy
I can hurt my hand punching them you
know break my break my like or break my
toe like kicking them you know a duds
for someone like you who fights at 115
pounds it's even more difficult right
because the lack of people that are your
size to train with in your also train a
lot with men and it's and it creates
crazy because at a professional level
like you're you're right there you know
you just beat the [ __ ] out of Hannah
cyphers it was a crazy fight thank you
but that was a big fight for you yeah
like you're you're in the heat right now
yeah you're right there so for you
you're you're you know you're at the top
of the heap in this championship realm
right and to train with people that are
bigger than you or to take chances like
that like there's no other sport that
would have that yeah you know yeah and
it's like the lack of women as well you
know because even if I'm training with
like a bantamweight if it's a woman like
it's not as dangerous as training with
like some of the bigger guys like the
like guys and girls are kind of like
different sizes like if I'm if I'm
training with a guy who fights at 1:15
he's gonna be like four foot tall you
know so it's a it's like the weight
distribution is different but like I
don't know something about I guess
training with women like the strength
the the force that's coming at you
versus the force you're giving to them
though I just feel like it's a lot safer
to train with lemon oh for sure yeah
[Applause]